usually for service based businesses the
best way to grow is through referrals
and word of mouth the connections wow
that's a lot of work that's a lifetime
of work welcome to another morning show
I'm gonna sit to be here with a new
friend in the Keisha yes thank you thank
you I'm a co-owner of a company called
beyond services choice matters and what
I do I specialize in customized service
for families with individual with
disability so basically a cater to your
needs so where what what is your pain
point
what's your stressful ear where do you
need me the most and that's where I come
in awesome so how can I help
so one of the biggest biggest help that
I think I need the most is because my
business is fairly new I just launched
it in January I want to be more vit the
visibility within a social media right
now my business is striving from word
amount which is awesome but to take it
to the next level I need to be able to
you know market more so oh so we were
talking quickly you know before you got
here early I love it it always show up
early I always show up early so your
service based business and and you're
very Geographic dependent yeah GTA right
so like Toronto area yeah usually for
service based businesses the best way to
grow is through referrals and word of
mouth the connections as opposed to
going and blasting online okay but the
challenge with it is yeah hello
everybody
you know I got people watching and tune
in but there are guys for joining
they're all over the world right nice
because my audience is global gopal yes
because what I do is not specific to the
city I think the best thing in the short
term is to start partnering up with
every agency with every government
program with every like having you speak
at local events I think you'll get a lot
more leverage next week I have a trade
show at a health and wellness or
ionization and I'm gonna be speaking
there as well so that's my speaking
career something that I'm developing as
well one of the challenges is to get to
get to the agencies what I'm currently
doing is sending out mails but I'm
trying to figure a way to target the
agencies more right to get referral
through the agency how many clients you
have now we have about seven so for each
so you've got seven clients they've been
in the system for a while oh yes yes yes
most of them from birth so and they're
on items all adults are two decades have
been in the system I think they're
anywhere between age twenty seven to
forty eight to forty eight yes Wow Wow
that's a lot of work that's a lifetime
of work it's creating anyway um what I'd
be doing is asking you form a close
friendship with the family yes yes yes
right like you're now part of their
family
yes your extended family yes nakisha
what I would do is ask them what are all
the agencies that they've used Oh over
there okay span and ask for an
introduction
okay I'm a business I'm trying to get
into more agencies who have you used
okay because we've used multiple yes
especially for someone who family with
individual disability you depend on ages
you depend on support cuz that's the
only way to really function you can't
really function on your own you need
other sources to come in to help you so
a so this person you working with us 48
yes how many agencies have they used I'm
not sure cuz right now they're currently
living at an agency with living they
they live in with an organization within
an organization so I go in within the
organization because they're not able to
because of shortage of staffing they're
not able to support this individual
group in the way that the parents want
them to be supported so I go into the
agency and I work with the individual
directly one-on-one alright I think you
build a million-dollar business
they'll ever having a post on social
media oh wow that's good to know because
that part is like okay the the problem
that I'm having with social media is to
find that time to do it right because
there's so much because most of my days
out and then when I'm home then I'm home
with the family and you know and trying
to do paperwork and sending out emails
cuz I have to send out emails to family
like you know yeah priority just like
everything else like how do you find
time for your kids
yeah after your husband how do you find
time for you make the time and putting
it down there how do I have time
yeah I don't I think for you it's
helpful to have a presence in that and
I'm happy to go I love social media but
at the wall we could talk all day the
strategies huh no problem I just know
that it serves you it probably wants to
get you where you need to go considering
it's a service based business and its
local yes what I would do is if I'm
looking at my main social platforms I
would have some I would make sure I have
a great picture
whether it's your face or whether it's
your yeah something I'd really fixed my
bio so it looks explains exactly what I
do and then I would have a few pieces of
content that that reflect why would your
thought leadership really well not even
just like here's what we do but your
approach like what makes you so
different from all the other agencies or
PSWs that are going in to work with
these people okay right and so your your
approach and why it's different why
you're special not here's why you should
hire us and that's what's working
because usually when we go into when
family when family's seekers is because
they are desperate for like the current
families that we have right now they're
desperate for support and the good thing
about us we're not traditional right we
offer something different from what the
traditional service offers so we're not
like this is what we offer you gotta buy
to this we come in it was like okay
where do you need us and we customize
our service based on the families right
so that's the unique so family kind of
like that cuz we're here we listen like
okay so what do you want where do you
need us you know what's your child so it
could
behavior right and a lot of time what
did you get you first seven to refer
yeah so one was an individual that I
know I work with with the agency that I
used to work with the others or through
people referring us and refer yeah so
dis chata offer front referral yeah so
yeah all of them is do or for all right
now and it's great we're busy five days
a week which is great yeah so the next
level is to get to that stage where we
could start hiring now right and just
grow the business
you could be million other business next
year just through referrals yes which is
crazy for a start-up yeah yeah funded
yeah it's all government funded which is
great it's not it's not money coming out
of pocket its money and and the good
thing about them they need to use up as
funding within the year in are they lose
it right right so it's not like they get
this fun and you got a pocket it they
get it's fun to use for service like me
and then they can use it every year
every year it's automatic system yeah
automatically they get it every year
such as every year to spend ago so it's
just to find those family one other
thing that I was taking to do was to we
are not competing with the agents no I'm
not competing with any agencies funding
their own yeah yeah I'm not competing
with anyone and I'm filling in the gap
so I'm not even computer with service so
what what we're doing we're giving the
additional service on top of what you
have every agency yes
so if they get is to get is to get it
and that that that's what we're trying
to figure out how to get in those doors
of the agencies so that's why we're
faking okay maybe if we go on like I was
even thinking like upgrading my social
media present and target those agencies
like the directors and stuff and start
bonding with with them is just to get
through because it's it's one thing to
send mails or send email because you
have the receptionist that weed out and
throw away your stuff right so how do I
get to the
targeted people that will listen and can
make those decision yeah so so if I'm
you I start with what I said which is
through all your connections yes and
then all of your clients asking them for
introductions okay cuz I'm sure they
would say yes what agencies have you
work with and would you mind making
introduction to the person by saying
okay that's a good one thank you they
would do it yeah they will do it good
and then they're every new client that
you on board and they're just it's
spreads yes you've got seven people
they've already worked with five
agencies oh yeah at least I think right
yeah some of them are still working with
at least five if they work with ten
agencies yeah that's seventy
introductions
and then what we find a lot of knowledge
yeah you're done you're done
yeah just give me just just following up
and connecting with 70 people there's a
lot of work it's a lot and that's it
it's just to get that this is such an
easy business
but you're done like you don't need to
overthink it because the next thing I
would say is okay yes what you could do
is on social if you look at Instagram
for example I would make sure that I had
nine really good pieces of content that
you post once like post before the end
of the year but really represent your
brand so that if somebody came to your
your page they say oh this is what they
do they sound like they're experts
yeah they look reputable I'm curious
it's not just some yeah random post and
that's that's the challenge good we
don't want to just put random posts we
wanted to do post that represent what we
do so I would have but I would just do
nine I'm just do not an Instagram I
would probably delete all the old ones
that you're not proud of I just have
nine and then I wouldn't worry about a
posting strategy I would be targeted
following all of the agencies in Toronto
I mean we are aware of all the agencies
well most of them not all but most of
them in the comment I'm going on their
stuff okay so then when they see it
they'll say Oh who's this company or was
this person they click on your account
and then they go to your cabin and they
see oh that's a good right I don't think
you even need to do that and that's a
good thing to know because we know we
have a good thing going on and we see
the potential and we see how much we've
grown you know I always talk to my
business partner and we're like oh my
goodness how many business within the
first year does this well like for a lot
of people they take several and that's
not much but for us it's a lot because
you're looking at the amount of funding
money that they're paid yeah they're
paying so so what we make within the
first year it's like a lot of business
don't make that within 5 years right so
it's like wow if we market it properly
and we target the right people you know
and it's ongoing and it's ongoing
yeah it's forever as long as they need
us right it's all going forever because
they need you forever because if you
start work with somebody at 20 yes and
they need us until 50 yeah yeah you'll
be retired before they stop leaving yeah
I know it's a good business and the good
thing about it we offer we offer a wide
range of service because we have the
mental piece we have the B of your piece
we have the parental piece that we offer
we have the training piece that we offer
you know and we bring our service to you
you don't have to come to us yeah I mean
now I mean as you grow it can't just be
you and your partner yeah hiring people
also making good margins yes hiring
people once you go to a certain size
they'll just be your reputation so your
business now is a very short term
marketing effort mm-hmm because you
could get to you know 100 to 150 in
revenue and you and your partner manage
everything yes are off like seeing all
the all the patients that our clients
are what I've been calling them and
checking in and could we have to still
be involved you'll be like you guys the
two you can handle everything yourself
in that range
and so to get to 150 in revenue is just
that it's just tapping everybody you
know and asking all your clients can you
yeah if we like yeah they're an early
2019 wait wait they January February
yeah beyond that though then the
marketing starts to snowball itself and
you won't have to worry as much about
the marketing yeah it'll still just be
who do you know yeah but if gesture do
the groundwork now then it then that
becomes easy then the real problem to
scale the business to the million-plus
is gonna be operations is gonna be
hiring it's gonna be building a team yes
that's he that scene that's the entire
problem to solve
oh I'll just kill can I get people who
represent my brain and we could even
we're able to go into the school as well
right we could hire stuff to go into
school board to work as well oh but you
don't have a you don't have a you won't
have a marketing problem mm-hmm
you'll get too many clients the the only
marketing probably you'll ever have is
if your name gets tarnished because yeah
putting the wrong people and then you
stop getting referrals if you just
follow that process of every time you
bring somebody new in you know you've
had some good results a month leaving
you you ask them hey would you mind
referring us as you build momentum and
more reputation and more trust the
referral tap just turns on even more and
boy yes we're you all have to even worry
about it we're just gonna come in which
is awesome yeah he didn't good work in
the community yes right as long as you
keep doing good work you'll just get
more and more pearls which is that most
people have a marketing problem beyond
this next three months you won't yeah if
you do a good job like if you follow up
with if you got 70 referrals you
wouldn't even have the time before
Christmas to meet everybody out and I've
coffee yeah right so you I like that if
you want to learn nine effective ways to
grow your business check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
what are some of the benefits of being
small that a business owner can leverage
to beat out the big guys I think the big
thing about being small is that you're
nimble that you're flexible
you